okay we've got a nicola fraud update the
electric car maker is
expecting a 125 million dollar fine and
trevor milton their former disgraced ceo
is scheduled to start his trial in april
their market cap has crashed massively
from 34 billion dollars to now under 5
billion to catch you up on what's
happened since he was on the podcast
milton was indicted on three counts of
fraud in july by the department of
justice each count carries a maximum
jail sentence of between 20 and 25 years
according to reuters that's a you know a
total of up to 75 years in prison if
they were served sequentially i'm not
sure about the law if those would be
served concurrently or sequentially um
but let's just break down the crazy year
and a half that nicola had to refresh
everybody in the audience they spacked
on june 3rd and they started trading as
nkla you can search for nkla and google
and get their stock history or in your
iphone app
and if you look at that history it is
dismal here's a chart for those of you
watching the youtube video at
youtube.com this week in
and it has been a massive fall from
grace
in late june nicola peaked at 34 billion
dollars uh as a market cap they were
trading at about 70 a share now they're
trading on 11 a share and they're worth
4.5 billion approximately i think with
no product and no revenue this is a 450
million dollar company
maximum i don't know what their cash
position is but i would give them like
one million dollars above their cash
position because they're going to be
embattled in lawsuits
they might even be better off just
giving everybody their cash back right
now so they're worth 4.5 billion right
now the cash positions around 500
million i would give them a valuation of
1 million dollars above their 500
million dollar cash position uh because
they're going to burn through 100
million on legal fees no doubt it's
going to be a complete disaster this
company will probably be a zero uh be
taken private uh and or just be delisted
that's my best prediction and i'm pretty
good at these things so uh we had trevor
milton on episode 1090 back in july of
2020. you all remember that episode if
you haven't seen it
it is uh if i'm if i dare say a virtuoso
performer performance
uh by me as an interviewer because i
kind of got the sense that this kid was
full of [ __ ] and i just let him talk
and some people are like you're being
too easy on him i made a strategic
decision
that me confronting him would not be as
effective as letting him talk because
the more he talked the wilder it got and
uh it got pretty wild
i had heard somebody as an interviewer
say a famous interview at some point
said you know just ask a very basic
question and let the person talk is
probably the best interview technique
that always stuck with me
uh at the time nicola was trading at
thirty dollars a share they had about a
thirteen billion dollar market cap
milton if you remember was ousted in
september of 2020
after activist short seller hindenburg
research they named these things
wonderfully uh published a report
alleging that nikola's contracts and
progress were greatly exaggerated and it
turns out that was true
uh we covered this on episode 11 12 in
september 2020 after the hindenburg
report was released
now in july of 2020 milton was indicted
by a federal grand jury on three counts
of fraud you can see episode 1256 for
that one quote from a u.s attorney that
worked on the case via the department of
justice press release and i'm quoting
here
as alleged trevor milton brazenly and
repeatedly used social media and
appearances and interviews on television
podcasts hmm and in print to make false
and miscellaneous claims about the
status of nicholas trucks and technology
they definitely watched our podcast but
one time i'll take a shout out from the
department of justice and be really
thrilled about it uh they definitely
watch our podcast and again trevor
milton's trial is scheduled to start on
april 4th
2022 in new york please let that one
be televised and i guess if it's a
federal one my understanding is federal
trials are not televised and and it's up
to the local jurisdictions if they will
be televised that's why theranose is not
televised
according to a freightwave's article
milton requested the trial be moved from
new york to arizona federal judge denied
this request because milton bought and
sold shares on the new york-based nasdaq
makes sense his defense as per the
freightwaves.com article quote milton
claimed he should not have been charged
in new york for securities fraud and
wire fraud because his alleged illegal
behavior occurred in arizona where
nicholas headquartered or utah where he
lives i guess he wanted the home court
uh advantage and he is not going to get
it on july 29th milton surrendered to
authorities pled not guilty to the
charges and was freed on a hundred
million dollars in bail quite a bail
payment interestingly he used two
properties in utah as collateral for
bell according to cnbc he bought a 2 000
acre riverside estate in utah for 32.5
million in november of 2019
pretty good looking house i might put a
bid in on this when it goes to um
when this goes to auction i i'm yeah i
could put 20 million on that one and i
could have all the naughty gang come
over and we'll have a big party for this
weekend startups at that 2000
acre estate that's pretty good this was
after he sold secondary shares during a
250 million dollar raise that valued
nicola at 3.2 billion dollars in
september of 2019.
so you can check out milton's estate
according to the late times it's the
most expensive residential purchase in
utah history which is surprising because
i think 32 million is the average
apartment in manhattan right now uh and
the average starter home in la he's also
facing civil securities for our charges
from the sec uh milton sold another 70
million worth of stock in the pipe
that's the private investment in a
public entity when you do a spec you
could also put together a pipe letting
private investors uh invest in that
public enter entity and i asked him
about this on episode 10 90.
uh you can check out his answer in this
2 minute and 30 second clip from our
interview i'll play the whole thing so
you can hear it the spac
puts the money in you have a pipe a
private investment in a public entity
that occurs at the same time but then
you sell 70 million dollars in shares at
that same time is that correct yep yeah
that's something people were really
critical of like why if you're so long
the vision would you take 70 million off
the table in you know before the
products even launched that that was a
red flag of red flags for me and for
others
yeah there's a lot of people have asked
me and criticized me and here's here's
the real answer to it when we did um
when we were going through this the pipe
put in all their money at 10 you know at
the 10 share um
price essentially which is the pre-ipo
price for everybody um the stack put in
the the thing at ten dollars as well and
the and the the the pipe these big funds
like fidelity um psam you know all these
different groups that we're in that are
in here um blackrock all these other
groups they came in they said look you
got too much control way too much um you
own the board you own what was your
ownership at that point percentage-wise
ballpark well i gave up a lot so i had
70 of the company and i gave about 30 to
my employees um i wanted them to all
become rich and so i gave i wanted them
all become you know i don't want all the
money myself i want to share it with i
want to share with people that are
30
employee stock option pool and
well i gave away probably about
15 directly and then the other 15
through the option
so it was oh it was over 30 percent of
my stock was diluted it was
taking off 30 of the top to to those
guys
and i still had 40 percent of the
company yeah and uh
and i'll make you know hundreds of
people wealthy in their generations to
come after it and that's what i like in
life but the answer to why this sock was
sold is they came to me they said look
we want you to we don't want you to be
the ceo and the executive chairman you
got to choose one or the other
and i and i asked him why i said what's
your reason and they said well it's not
healthy to have one voice everywhere to
control everything and i said
i can see that that's actually some
wisdom in that and they said we want you
to have a lo we want you to be locked up
longer we want you to be here for a long
period of time we want you to take one
dollar salary and also the whole
executive team this is what's not this
is what this is what no one ever
reported on all they did is report on
the bad right because it gets headlines
so the entire executive team came in and
said okay we're gonna take one dollar
salary
and that's and we get stock bonuses
that's it and they said trevor we want
you to reduce down some of that some of
that control
and they said we'll buy some of those
shares from you so you can live on this
you're not focused on
money during the time that you are
running this company we want you to have
some money out now it's smart and we
want you to focus on nikola not focus on
how you're going to pay your bills or
pay for your house or whatever else all
right i'm getting a lot of grant cardone
vibes from that guy or like billy
mcfarland there's great polls from my
nerdy chat room now telling me yeah who
that guy who does that guy remind you of
when he talks my god it seems
like he is uh
yeah
he just seems like he is working you in
the interview
all around the world tech companies are
innovating and driving returns for
investors don't i know it well our crowd
analyzes many of these companies and
they search across the global private
market then they select the ones with
the greatest growth potential and
finally they bring them to us me and you
from personalized medicine to cyber
security to robotics and quantum
computing and much more whether it's in
a state-of-the-art lab a startup garage
or anywhere in between our crowd
identifies innovators so you can invest
when growth potential is greatest which
is early our crowd accredited investors
have already invested over one billion
dollars in growing tech companies and
many of their members have benefited
from 46 ipos or exits now you can truly
diversify your portfolio by investing
early in innovative private market
companies at our crowd join the fastest
growing venture capital investment
community at ourcrowd.com twist that's
rcrout ourcrowd.com
twist to sign up for free today